ohne alkohol würde unsere gesellschaft
auseinander brechen da wusste er war
ehrlich sein also alkohol hält
deutschland zusammen er schon
zwei großereignisse von weltrang fanden
in dieser woche in düsseldorf statt zum
einen die größte spirituosen messe der
welt und die aktionswoche alkohol also
dagegen wohin zuerst da fiel die
entscheidung nicht schwer
wir waren gerade eben beim röderer
flasche champagner kristall 250 euro
gratis einfach direkt rein mit dem ding
so war es ja ja sechs gläser zakir
wollen ja heute auch ein bisschen
deutschland feiern bei tatsächlich ist
ja so dass es in deutschland die die
wenigsten beschränkungen gibt was
alkoholkonsum angehen und das finden wir
es mal eine gute sache also aus sicht
des herstellers und vertrieb las ist das
auf jeden fall eine gute sache es gibt
ja in anderen ländern zwar steht in
holland trägt neben dran da darf ich
fachhandel für spirituosen wein in einer
bestimmten schule kindergärten gar nicht
eröffnen man sagt ja kinder und
betrunkene sagen immer die wahrheit ist
oft mehr kinder wie sieht es mit
besoffenen kindern
mein papa hatte an seine an die
gastgeber hatten ein wandgemälde machen
lassen und da waren wirklich betrunkene
kinder drauf ach ja also ich heute noch
sieht man kann man heute noch sehen und
dieses etikett wo er dann kreiert hatte
wurde in amerika abgelehnt weil die
gesagt haben also kinder die besoffen
tinkerbell ja nicht verkaufen spießer
oder was soll man da sagen haben was ist
denn jetzt eigentlich das problem beim
alkohol alkohol ist ein lösungsmittel
das löse beziehung es löst konnten auf
das löst familien und wenn man von der
sucht direkt oder indirekt betroffen ist
dann leidet man einfach unter dieser
sache ich möchte es auch nicht verkaufen
wenn die denn die jugend sich
ausprobiert und wenn die leute beim
essen wein trinken und wird das will das
will ich gar nicht verteufeln nur
wenn strukturiert werbung für gemacht
wird da muss man halt auch
klare kante reden was damit passieren
können
[Musik]
das hat mich nicht
man darf also wein ist sehr zu empfehlen
man darf nicht empfehlen dass es für die
gesundheit ist das ist gesetzlich
verboten deswegen hier ein kleiner
flinker smiley oder schon ironisch wir
wissen beide kommen so richtig startet
du dich ja haben es besser brauchen
generell wobei natürlich 62.000 tote pro
jahr ja aber ich sag mal was haben wir
denn auf den autobahn
wie geht's euch denn wunderbar vielen
dank ist es herrlich ihre eintrittskarte
schon raus gesoffen wir machen das immer
so vertrieb gesagt gerade sondern
einfach loslaufen
relations
am besten was hochprozentiges das geht
schnell sie neben weniger kalorien zu
sich was im prinzip aber auch im kreis
weil alkohol entfettet jaja und dadurch
das ja wohl entfettet nehmen sie quasi
nicht zu sein eigentlich ab also eine
ganz gesunde sache das ist eigentlich
voll im lifestyle trend er sieht nun vor
dass für die gesundheit ja dann ab dafür
let's get happy darauf
[Musik]
gut dass galas oder kein idol aber
lecker alter schwede genau der untergang
ist aber mit wein ist sehr viel
erträglicher und darauf trinken wir
jetzt post und damit zurück ins studio
[Musik]
[Applaus]
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
wie laminat die freimaurer staatsführung
ist alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
erst bei so vielen abonnenten auf
youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten